[Music]
hello
my name is eric from the university of
california san francisco
today i'm going to talk to you about
illumina next generation sequencing
sample preparation
so for today's talk we'll do a brief
review of next generation sequencing
then we'll cover dna and rna library
preparation methods
followed by that we'll go over bead base
sample cleanups which are used
really commonly in a lot of these
protocols and will end with sample
quantification
and qc of your libraries so first a
brief review of luminous sequencing
and as a reminder we do have a video of
this on the ibiology website that goes
into more
more depth so luminous sequencing occurs
in these flow cells depicted on the
left-hand side and it's an optical
sequencing method
within these flow cells are oligos that
are on the surface of the flow cell that
capture
libraries that are to be sequenced and
to prepare these libraries we need to
add adapters which are these colored
portions onto our inserts that we want
to sequence
once a library has been captured onto
the surface of the flow cell through
multiple rounds of
amplification you generate other strands
and eventually you generate many many
copies of each of these strands
on the surface of these flow cells and
these clusters
of molecules are what get sequenced and
over here i'm just depicting a schematic
of how the sequencing works
so if we were to imagine that we have
several different clusters
of different molecules on the surface of
the flow cell
and we run through the sequencing
process where each of the bases are
labeled by a different color
and we do this for multiple cycles we
can build up the sequence of each of
those
individual molecules and so if you
follow the top left
cluster which is yellow on the first
cycle over here you can see that it
starts off
as a yellow color then becomes blue red
red green and if we use the color scheme
over here we can decode that as
an agcct with the bottom right hand
cluster
it's blue green yellow yellow and then
red
and this can be decoded as gtaac
and so dna library preparation is a
process of adding those adapters that
allow
your dna molecules to become captured
and then sequenced
onto these illumina sequencing
instruments
and so the goal is to add those adapters
and there are two different methods that
i'll cover
today for dna library preparation these
are true seek style
and xterra style methods and then i'll
go over enrichment strategies
in for the process of selecting certain
dna molecules that you want to sequence
so with truseq style dna library
preparation you begin with dna
that's a long long molecule depicted in
gray
on the top left-hand side the first step
is to fragment that dna into smaller
bits that are appropriately sized for
the luminous sequencers
and these are generally generally in the
hundreds of bases
of length this fragmentation results in
dna fragments
that are not polished so they have
certain overhangs
on different ends and the first step to
repair those ends
is to blunt the ends using a mixture of
different enzymes
this will generate double stranded dna
that has no overhangs
and the next step is to add a single a
base so that you have
a single a overhang on your dna
inserts and this allows the next step
which is ligation of the adapters so the
adapters
are these colored molecules over here
and these adapters have a t
overhang that allows it to base pair
with the a overhangs on your inserts
and this undergoes a ligation reaction
and at this point you have a complete
library that can go on for sequencing
if you don't have enough material you
can amplify this up using pcr
using primers that prime off of the
adapter sequences that you've located on
and you can generate
many copies and so this would be a pcr
prep to do the amplification you can
also have pcr for your preps
where you don't do any pcr amplification
if you have enough material
and these can both of these molecules
can go
onto the sequencer
another method of preparing dna
libraries is this nextera process which
takes advantage of this
property of transposases that allow them
to insert
dna molecules into other large pieces of
dna
so again if we start with let's say
genomic dna that hasn't been fragmented
and we add these transpose enzymes that
have the adapter sequences
loaded onto them these transposases will
insert these dna sequences into the dna
and actually fragment them into smaller
bits so in a single reaction
you fragmented the dna and added partial
adapters
the next step is to undergo a pcr
reaction
that'll use these partial adapters as
priming sites for the pcr reaction
to complete the library preparation and
add the rest of the adapter sequences
onto the molecules so with these nextera
dna library preps you do have to do
pcr there isn't a pcr-free version that
you can do
[Music]
so a lot of times you may not want to
sequence every piece of dna that's in
your sample
and let's say that for instance you're
only interested in the coding regions of
the human genome which makes up a small
percentage of the entire genome
it'd be a waste to sequence the entire
sample because you're sequencing
mostly things that you're not interested
in and so there are different enrichment
strategies
that allow you to target specific areas
of the genome of your or your sample
for sequencing and so in this case let's
pretend that the regions in pink
and the dna are the reach that you want
to sequence
the first method is a capture based
method and this method you generate
a standard dna sequencing library using
either that nextera or that truseq
library prep method that we went over
earlier but once you've created that
library you have a mixture of molecules
that have both the regions of interest
in pink but also these regions of
interest
that aren't of interest in gray you have
a panel of dna oligos
that bind to your regions of interest
that also have a biotin molecule
attached to it
so you take your dna that includes both
regions of interest
and not interest you add in these probes
that allow you to capture specifically
those pink areas of interest and then
you'll pull them down with beads using
that biotin handle you do some washes
and at the end you have enriched for
molecules that include those regions of
interest
a second method is to use pcr
amplification using lots and lots of
different pcr primers
and in this method you start with your
genomic dna and you design
primer sets that will amplify up your
regions of interest
and these primers also have partial
lumen adapters
at the end you undergo around or several
rounds of pcr to amplify up these
regions
and you wind up with some enrichment but
you don't have a complete library at
that point
what you need to do is a second pcr
reaction
to add on the final portions of the
illumina adapter to get a sequencable
molecule